if the white house was a circus
joe biden would be plate spinner in
chief
as he enters into his second year in the
oval office good afternoon he's got a
lot to do both internationally and
domestically this is a worldwide
challenge and the consequences if one of
the plates fall
could be the effective end of his
presidency by the end of the year
top of the list of challenges like it
was when he was sworn in is covered
after confidently claiming he was in his
words kicking the viruses but in july it
came roaring back and now omicron has to
be dealt with
a lockdown is unlikely another economic
shock isn't and with job numbers not
where they should be and the cost of
basic goods rising president biden needs
some good news for american families
he delivered an infrastructure bill his
build back better bill is essentially
dead
but he still believes he can get parts
of it through congress increasing help
to american families
but some washington watchers say he
still has other campaign promises to
deliver democrats have been so badly
out messaged and their messaging is so
atrocious that
even with build back better they're
going to have a difficult time they have
lost the battle the messaging battle on
inflation and inflation is indeed
hurting a lot of americans november
brings midterm elections normally
considered a referendum on those in the
white house i'm not recommending for
every future president that they take a
shellacking like they like i did last
night
biden has an approval rating of under 50
percent that could mean him losing the
house maybe even the senate now try
getting anything done in washington with
both houses not in your control what is
happening in ukraine so he could turn to
foreign policy to get wins before the
2024 presidential election where those
closest to him say he'll run again
the pictures of the frantic withdrawal
from afghanistan haunt the biden white
house if the country again becomes a
base for islamic militants he'll bear
the burden for the failures of his and
other administrations
he wants a new nuclear deal with iran
there are talks but they have to deliver
america is worried about china's growing
influence its expanded military its
economic power talks between the two
leaders effectively went nowhere
and then there's russia with cyber
attacks increased activity on the
ukraine border biden's white house seems
to be waiting to respond to what comes
next i think he's already had some
important foreign policy successes i
think that the united states has sent a
strong signal to russia with european
partners that if russia invaded ukraine
it would pay
major
costs and i think that's likely to
continue to deter russia from invading
ukraine going forward as biden heads
into the new year he's hoping delivering
big domestic success will make americans
feel better about where the country is
going we can deliver real people
results that they're going to affect
their lives but if they don't they could
decide they don't like the act
and it's time for the biden circus to
move on
alan fisher al jazeera washington